[Música]
la capital de Canadá despliega a la
policía contra las protestas de Los
camioneros he notado a las autoridades
han arrestado al menos a 170 personas
que se manifestaban enfrente del
parlamento para rechazar la vacunación
contra el 19
en El Salvador Crean un bloque de
búsqueda para encontrar a los
desaparecidos a iniciativa en los
familiares que denuncian la falta de
acción por parte de las autoridades en
un país donde no se sabe con exactitud
Cuántas personas han sido
voluntarios buscan en el lodo en el
sureste de Brasil esperan poder
encontrar más sobrevivientes después del
deslizamiento de tierra del martes que
dejó más de 100 muertos hasta ahora han
rescatado con vida a una veintena de
personas
Bienvenidos a las noticias de América
esto es tras 24 y mi nombre es María
Clara calle y comenzamos esta emisión
hablando de que al menos 170 personas
han sido arrestadas entre el viernes y
el sábado en Ottawa la capital de Canadá
según el jefe de la policía local las
autoridades replegaron a los
transportistas que se manifestaban en
frente del parlamento para rechazar la
vacunación contra el covi 19 las
protestas Ya llevan tres semanas Ariana
villacorta tiene los detalles
de pimienta y granadas de aturdimiento
la policía canadiense hizo retroceder a
los manifestantes del convoy de la
libertad de Motagua y retomo finalmente
el control de las calles frente al
parlamento en una de las operaciones
policiales más grandes en la historia de
Canadá
iniciales provenientes de todo el país
a los residentes del centro estamos
enfocados en su seguridad Nos iremos a
ninguna parte hasta que recuperemos sus
calles estamos preparados estamos al
tanto de los manifestantes que abandonan
el recinto parlamentario y se trasladan
a los vecinios circundantes estamos
trabajando con nuestros socios y
Sacaremos a estos manifestantes
pacíficamente de su área esta operación
sigue adelante no ha terminado y tomará
más tiempo hasta que hayamos logrado
nuestros objetivos
también confesó que había utilizado los
poderes de emergencia para encautar 76
cuentas bancarias conectadas a
manifestantes valorizadas en
aproximadamente 3,2 millones de dólares
y recomendó a los que envían alimentos
al sitio de protestas a destinarlo a
otras organizaciones benéficas
en el parlamento para esta agencias es
una locura hasta el momento las
autoridades han arrestado al menos 170
personas y han remolcado casi dos
docenas de vehículos irónicamente el 90%
de Los camioneros transfronterizos en
contra de las vacunas y mandatos por
cobit 19 tienen su esquema de vacunación
completos según la caneidian trucking a
lions
es un espacio seguro y supervisado donde
los consumidores de sustancias
psicoactivas pueden ejercer el consumo
de forma segura se trata de un intento
por frenar el aumento en las muertes por
sobredosis en las calles en Estados
Unidos deja miles de fallecidos cada año
Marina sardina tiene la historia
con el lema este sitio salvavidas
escrito en la entrada Nueva York abre el
primer centro de inyección de drogas en
Estados Unidos un esfuerzo en la lucha
contra la sobredosis que solo en 2020
mataron a más de 2000 personas en la
ciudad básicamente
si vas a consumir si vas a seguir
consumiendo déjanos enseñarte a consumir
de forma
seguradores de sustancias acuden al
centro para drogarse de forma segura
pero allí también les ofrecen atención
médica lavandería comida caliente y
asesorías
los llevan a una habitación especial y
en la sala hay entre dos y tres miembros
del personal conformación médica por si
algo va mal tienen habitaciones
separadas para los fumadores de crack
cabinas con espejos con iluminación
completa para los usuarios de
inyecciones
a nivel nacional las muertes por
sobredosis aumentaron a más de 100.000
el año pasado la mayoría relacionadas
con sobredosis de fentanilo y otras
sustancias sintéticas
estamos en un punto increíblemente malo
en el que hemos tenido el mayor aumento
de muertes en Estados Unidos y en Canadá
añadiría en la historia de cualquiera de
estos países
vicios que salvan vidas sigue
polarizando a la sociedad Ahora nos
vamos a Centroamérica los familiares de
desaparecidos en El Salvador decidieron
hacer un bloque de búsqueda para
encontrar a sus seres queridos Aunque
reconocen que es una labor del Estado
dicen que las autoridades han sido
indiferentes con sus casos previamente
Italia Cepeda responsable del área
jurídica de la asociación salvadoreña
por los Derechos Humanos nos habló sobre
si las autoridades han avanzado o no en
la lucha contra este flagelo
con la Comisión Interamericana solicitud
de las organizaciones sociales no ha
existido un avance hemos solicitado la
creación de un sistema único de un
registro serio de personal desaparecidas
hemos solicitado la aprobación de
legislación especial y por supuesto la
ratificación de los tratados
internacionales y ninguna de estas
medidas se ha tomado por parte del
Estado no sean fortalecido de las
instituciones de investigación y
búsqueda ni tampoco estamos viendo
acciones de prevención en cuanto a la
seguridad que es un problema muy grave
que vive el país con el crimen
organizado
se están buscando entre el fango a las
víctimas de los deslizamientos de tierra
en Brasil Homero si voluntarios han
realizado la búsqueda desde el martes en
la ciudad de petrópolis
que dejaron más de 100 muertos al menos
26 de ellos eran niños
puse a votar las esperanzas de encontrar
sobrevivientes hasta ahora las
autoridades dicen que 24 personas han
sido rescatadas con vida y eso ocurrió
principalmente en las primeras horas
después de la tragedia
en los 46 años que llevo viviendo aquí
estoy seguro de que en cuanto vuelva el
sol y el tiempo se mantenga así los
políticos dejarán de preocuparse por
nosotros
Así que la gente limpiara por su cuenta
volverá a construir y al cabo de un
tiempo volverá a ocurrir lo mismo
y en Bolivia la ex presidenta interina
Yanina Yáñez completa 11 días de huelga
de hambre el viernes un juez autorizó
que la política fuera trasladada hacia
un centro de salud desde la cárcel donde
está retenida desde marzo de 2021 y el
sábado la defensoría rechazó esta
postura cuestionando la decisión de
medicar a años en contra de su voluntad
al frente del penal hubo manifestaciones
a favor de la ex mandataria años está
recluida preventivamente señalada por la
izquierda de organizar un golpe de
estado
Desde el miércoles la frontera de chile
está en estado de emergencia una medida
decretada por el gobierno de Sebastián
Piñera tras el corte de vías por parte
de camioneros que denunciaba en un
aumento de la inseguridad esta situación
está afectando a los miles de migrantes
que tratan de llegar al país austral
informa a Luis Muñoz
es el desgarrador llanto de la migración
este viernes en Chile las autoridades
expulsaron a decenas de personas a
Bolivia un drama para miles de
venezolanos como Isabel Camargo
hay un improvisado campamento para los
migrantes que logran cruzar desde
Bolivia donde está nacionadas entre 200
y 400 personas a 3700 m del nivel del
mar enfrentándose al incremente
altiplano se encuentran con el rechazo
de autoridades y parte de la población
chilena
3000 ingresos irregulares a Chile en
2021 fueron más de 23.000 chile tiene
cerca de 1,5 millones de migrantes y
según la organización internacional para
las migraciones es el tercer país con
más migrantes de América Latina después
de Argentina y Colombia
[Música]